c'est une première dans un centre
commercial français la marque
abercrombie and fitch créé en 1892 aux
états unis a ouvert le 18 octobre
dernier à west fils de parly 2 le second
magasin de l'enseigné en france après
les champs elysées pourquoi dans un
centre tout simplement pour être plus
proche du client
on souhaite se développer en france et
partout en france donc effectivement ait
choisi c'était intéressant beaucoup de
tourisme et pour nos l'opposera les
centres commerciaux premier abercrombie
and fitch dans un centre a parlé et bien
d'autres encore on l'espère au total le
magasin dispose de 300 m² pour exposer
ses collections homme et femme
les cabines insolites ont également été
installées tout se trouvera ici et je
vous fais le test voit la lumière on
peut augmenter ou pas vous avez
différents types de lumière standard
ailleurs sara johnson
niall excusez moi pour l'accent anglais
et la musique mon compte a eu quoi que
ce soit besoin d'être d'un conseil où
fait guy vasseur ring et on en a aussi
qui est automatiquement le message et
viendra nous aider avec l'arrivée de
l'enseignent le centre aux 11,3 millions
de visiteurs en 2018 espère montrer les
muscles et encore booster sa
fréquentation
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'à l'heure
combien c'est une marque internationale
extrêmement connue outre-atlantique
d'abord puis en france sur les
champs-elysées
c'est quand même extraordinaire de faire
venir la la le deuxième magasin ici dans
l'ouest par exemple avec cette ouverture
une quarantaine d'emplois ont été créés
le magasin pourrait recruter les
effectifs supplémentaires pour la
période de noël